how many screenplays have you sold sold
I haven't sold any I've sold couple
shorts which is bizarre to me that
there's a market for shorts but
apparently there there is there's even
um I've heard of some actually big sales
of shorts in fact one of the people who
has one of my features optioned right
now they got their start working for a
producer who was making short films for
like Sony and they were giving him like
$100,000 budget and each of these short
film yeah I'm like I don't I don't know
what they did with with $100,000 short
film at that point but there was
apparently a market for him so I sold
two shorts I've been hired to write a
bunch of shorts
I've optioned I currently have three
features that are out an option but
total I've optioned seven features that
I've had options than they didn't turn
into sales I know one of them was
because like they couldn't get the
director that they wanted and they be I
said in their mind was that director or
nobody sort of things so they'd one had
optioned a thriller script of mine and
then when they were looking for
investments they found an investor to
give them like a very large sum of money
but only if it was for a slate of
family-friendly features and mine did
not fit the bill and so yeah it
unfortunate went away but yeah I've got
of the three they're currently option
two of them are supposed to turn into
sales within the next couple of months
so I'm hoping that that works out but
yeah so far I don't have any like
full-on feature sales as of as of today
so can you explain the optioning process
sure so an option is kind of like a
rent-to-own sort of scenario you see
like those you know if you're going
Craigslist looking for an apartment or
something like lease-to-own sort of
things on like condos and stuff so it's
sort of that situation where they will
pay you an obscenely small amount of
money sometimes as little as a dollar to
have the rights to the script for
between six months in a year usually so
that way you can't be shopping there
onto other people so they know they're
the only person who has the ability to
make that movie and they're going around
trying to find either talent or
investments or both so then they can
raise the money to make the movie
if they succeed then they will buy the
script from you so then they can make it
if they don't succeed their options are
either a renew the option for a slightly
less low amount of money so if it was a
dollar the first time around it might be
like okay now we got pay you like five
hundred bucks you know - in order to get
like an additional year or they can just
be like okay we couldn't get it done
it's yours again do it what you want
with it so I've had scripts that after
that first year they couldn't do
anything with it so it's mine again one
of the three that I've optioned right
now they've renewed the option like
three times so I don't I don't know what
I know they they've had like different
successes and failures with it along the
way so I'm hoping that they get more
successes but until then I'm getting
money every year just for them to keep
being able to shop it around sort of
things so yeah that's that's what an
option is they pay you a little amount
to have the rights to shop it around and
then which is slightly remember shopping
agreement because you know shopping
agreement unless it's an exclusive
shopping agreement like you could still
potentially sell to other people
shopping even an exclusive shopping
agreement they are getting the rights to
like bring it around but they can only
bring it to like select people they
can't just like blanket the town with it
with under a shopping agreement you know
they have to go to specific either
investors or networks or if it's TV or
feature like I currently have I've one
of my scripts out on a shopping
agreement I have a shopping agreement
that I own on a book that I wanted to
adapt so for the shopping agreement
there was like no money and I can only
shop it around to specific people like I
can't I can't even tell people what the
script is unless it's a producer who can
get it made like you know so nobody
everyone knows that oh I wrote an
adaption but they're like why why can
you tell me what it is because my
shopping agreement is that I
only shop it to people who can buy it so
nobody else can even know it exists
other than knowing that I've wrote it
you know and they can't know what what
the script is then go find the book
great like that so and a similar thing
on the script that I have out with the
producer it's on shopping agreement is
that they can only talk about it to
investors or other producers like they
can't even talk like try to get like a
star or anything like that until it's
either an option agreement over sale so
yeah where does one submit for these
optioning opportunities um so there's
lots of ways to do that there's a bunch
of websites that have producers are
looking for specific stuff that you can
pitch things to like there's ink tip is
a screenwriting staffing Mandy used to
but I think they kind of backed off on
doing script stuff I think it's mostly
actors now for Mandy but they're like
you know you pay a certain amount of
money at um either like every month or
every quarter to basically get a
newsletter from them of producers are
looking for specific things then you
pitch your stuff to them and then if
they dig it then they'll option or buy
it and if not and they say thanks but no
thanks you can pitch stuff in query
letters query emails mostly now you get
like an IMDB Pro account you can gain
access to not all of them but a large
amount of industry people you can get
like their email or a phone number at
least of where they work you know like
if you want to go after like a rep you
know like if you want go like to you
know a TA or something you know you can
get the in contact information for the
company producers a lot of times the
producers will have like contact for
their production company and then they
might even have their own personal
contact on there see some of them query
letters and it's the same sort of thing
you know if they like it great if not oh
well meeting people in person doing
networking you know I've one of my
things I optioned was through a
Craigslist ad oh there's lots of
different avenues to find the producer
you know to get your stuff out there
yeah I would say Craigslist can be like
the most amazing experience or horrific
it's a lot of Craigslist because there's
so many scams on Craigslist you know
there's a lot of things out there that
but it's long as you're getting great
stuff there yeah I you know I have a
producer I met on there who has now
hired me to write like seven short films
only two of them got produced that I
know of
but you know I would and you know
because it's a short there's not a whole
lot of money but it's like that's stuff
I can pump out in a day basically you
know to write legal five-page thing for
him you know and make a little cash to
you know pay for guests that week and
then like it's also as long as you're
vetting the people you know making sure
that they're not some like schmuck who's
like oh yeah I'm gonna make a movie you
know IMDB whether you have the pro
version or if you're just my Andy being
someone you can still find out like what
they've done Google of course you can
just Google people look them up on you
know like if you like a search form on
like variety or deadlines or anything
like that you know you can find out if
they have a track record of any kind or
if there's somebody making their very
first script or movie and even if they
are making the very course movie doesn't
necessarily mean they're gonna scam you
it means they haven't done anything yet
you know and and those can be very good
relationships too you know you get in
with somebody who it's their very first
script that they're gonna be producing
they may not have the budget to do like
some big sale and big production movie
and stuff but you get in it's still a
produced credit which is much better
than not having it reduce credit you
know it's a terrible movie having that
credit is is more useful to you than
like just holding on to your babies and
not you know selling your stuff or
shopping your stuff around and I always
find to if the urgency of how fast
somebody wants you to do something if
it's like it's gotta be now or never
that's a red flag yeah sure I mean I get
things moved quickly but if you're
getting like a weird feeling and they're
talking in circles sometimes that's a
yeah there's there's definitely people
are doing the fake to make it sort of
stuff
when I was two living in Michigan I'm
gonna get Anaka naming names but when I
was living in Michigan there was a
producer who was had that sort of thing
we're like oh we have to sign this now
now now and it just wasn't a good deal
and they were gonna like get way more
out of it than I ever would have you
know and they hadn't done anything and
they were like I don't even know if some
of the things they were saying are true
or not but like they are making like
landish claims you know like the
outlandish claims of who they had deals
with you know of like distributor
companies and stuff they already had
like the first look deals with and stuff
like that which may have been true never
know but it's one of those things that
like it didn't seem true and when I
looked them up there was nothing to
support their claim that's a big right
doesn't necessarily mean it wasn't true
I was like I was mentioning before the
cameras rolling you know like there's a
writer that I know who he makes like 300
grand per draft but if you look to him
and he only has two produced credits but
he's written on like hundreds of things
you know it's or Carrie Fisher
you know she you know if you look to her
behind me you see all her acting stuff
you only seen your writing stuff but she
was like one of the biggest you know
ghost writers in town you know being
paid to like do touch-ups and stuff and
she was getting paid very well to fix
these scripts you know but you would
never know it by looking up on IMDB you
know so people could make claims that
are totally true you just can't find any
information on but if you can't find
information on it right but then like
you said then the urgency and then if it
skiff it's like confusing and it
shouldn't be configured at the deals and
have a lawyer look at the deals too you
can like attorneys if it's an attorney
that if you if you think you're gonna
have a long relationship with the
attorney you can probably convince them
to do a percentage deal as opposed to
paying them hourly that's what I have
with my attorney who does all my
contracts I've been with him since 2013
now and he gets you know a percentage of
anything I made from any of these deals
which for him could be a ton of money if
I hit something big you know if I were
to sell my James hooks to like Warner
Brothers and get paid like a million
bucks and his 5% of that
boxes a crapload of money where as if
nothing happened she doesn't get any
money so it's kind of like a risk on his
part two but one that he was willing to
make because he saw potential of having
deals in the future and you know I at
this point I'm like I I want I need one
of those big deals so I can give him his
5% can be more money than you know
paying his rent for a month or something
you know like the man deserves to live
wealthy you know because he does such he
bust his butt you know to to get me good
deals and make sure that I don't sign
anything that is not assignable so how
many are indispensable if you get even
if you have to pay one hourly you know
if you're gonna make it have a deal that
you're gonna make a few thousand bucks
on or something like that it might be
worth it to pay somebody like 100 bucks
an hour to look this over make sure that
you're not signing your soul away for
pennies you know 100 bucks an hour
that's how expensive oh yeah I I've seen
most it so if you get like an
entertainment lawyer there they could be
as low as 100 bucks an hour they could
be as high as 500 bucks an hour it kind
of pens you got I got shop around just
you would you know with any rep or like
I said my guy I know my guy I didn't
have his 5% his rates 130 an hour which
is still not bad when you know most of
these things whatever but but the thing
is though you you can't really pressure
him into doing everything one hour you
know like you said they're like an
11-page contract you know you're not
gonna get given if it's 100 bucks no
you're not you're gonna be paying at
least 300 bucks I guarantee you you know
so it's one of the things you just kind
of gotta wait you know if it's gonna be
like a little dollar option thing maybe
not but yeah lawyers are indispensable
because they're the ones they're gonna
find all the stuff that is a big red
flag that you would never know because
all this legalese it talks and circles I
I understand some of it now that I've
had enough contracts over the years so I
know things to look out for but there's
still stuff that my attorney and their
attorney will be having red lines back
and forth that I have no idea why this
is a bad
and why why I shouldn't sign but if my
tracing no then no and it's harder now
because you know before there's your
late 2013 late or early 2014 they
changed the laws a little bit with what
attorneys can even do for you because it
used to be my lawyer was able to talk
directly to the producers you know on
these deals and they could just discuss
the contract them between themselves I
could just sit back let them do their
job
but then the law changed like Suzy I
came here for the end of 2013 began in
2014 where now he can't he can be them
he can do all the redlining on the
contract but he's not even allowed to
have to take a phone call with the
producer that I'm I'm working on because
it'll count as him doing an agent's work
okay that point okay it's all I guy I
have a deal right now that the the
producer isn't really understanding that
he's getting very angry that you know
like my attorney won't talk but it's
like it's not he won't talk to you he
can't legally talk to you you know and
you know it's one of the things that he
could he could talk to you and like risk
everything by doing this you're just
like you know if you're talking on the
cell phone while you're driving you're
making a risk that you're gonna get
arrested for that you know or pay a bill
you know it's one of the things you can
I gotta weigh your options in my
attorney will not you know cross that
boundary just in case
you